[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to what would you do for a
million dollars it's not new pretty much
anything for less than a million dollars
a million dollars is a lot of money what
would you do for a million dollars when
I used to be a lot of money now the
billion dollars is like the million
dollars 2006 now a million it would be
two thousand two thousand sixteen years
ago yeah sure well even so a million is
not a billion in 2000 million dollars is
a life-changing amount of life-changing
amount of money like that is an
incredible I mean if you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year that's ten years
that's not you're doing well I mean
you're not just netting that but you're
making a six-figure income you're doing
wonderfully for yourself that's true so
anyway but this isn't the point what
we're asking is what would we do if
there were consequences attached to it
and that's where this game comes into
play okay so this game can be played a
whole bunch of different ways but we're
gonna play the version that is kind of
like cards against humanity' each of us
has drawn ten golden cards and he will
be the first judge so when he plays he's
gonna play a black card and read it
aloud to everybody here and then we are
gonna try to come up with the absolute
worst combination to go with that
specific card and he'll pick his
favorite and just to mix things up maybe
we should have a random card thrown into
fernanda I like random County like
random yeah if he picks the random one
we'll have to do a punishment
basically if random gets picked then the
two players who didn't go we'll pull a
Christmas cracker and then whoever loses
gets punished how's that sound
sounds great sounds Christmasy can I eat
those there's not food even gets
punished who's gonna get punished
I'd never double I thought they were
food no Christmas cracker does not mean
food alright not a cracker
[Laughter]
are we ready yes the first card million
dollars but every time you get lost or
need directions does that mean every
time I use my phone GPS it's definitely
that's getting dressed all right yes no
don't do you think well slides that's a
lot since I move now pick them up
shuffle them up and decide which one you
every time I get lost I need directions
you must go to the nearest major road
hitchhike and go wherever the driver
takes you Oh lovely appropriate
everything you own shrinks to a quarter
of its normal size for 24 hours I would
be a lot of naked oh your car shrinks
yeah oh no I mean to a quarter of its
normal size mine wouldn't be that bad
the vehicle you have to read mean
compass Wow cover 2 come on mom mine
comes I don't even know what that is
that's good ok it in public
it didn't say out loud it didn't say out
loud
no cool ok which one is the absolutely
the worst is the worst
yeah this one's not it because I think
not reading it out loud is ok casually
in a bookstore or even mind comes I
don't think it would be that bad I don't
know would really judge you all that
maybe it's for a research project yeah
who knows a lot of naked or a lot of
Possible's a lot of fun you know there
could be a lot of good stories with this
one yeah so so I'm gonna say this is the
one I wouldn't want to shrinking one the
shrinking
I was I was the hitchhiking it was it
was
it was clever I got rid of the Rando
pretty quick yeah good job million
dollars but every time you have see a
store having a sale you learn exactly
when and how someone you know will die
that's actually kind of cool
someone's turd will appear in a random
place in your home there's a chance at
being the toilet there's a chance a
random place that there's a chance you
have to spit directly on someone and not
apologize that's I mean if that's
someone who's finished
wait a second you spit on a lot of
people anyway like wait and recording I
think this means like like not just spit
while you talk back it's you spit is
spit regarding horse yeah Gavin a nice
Louie oh yeah didn't say loogie
it'd actually be interesting to know
exactly when and how someone you know
will die I mean it doesn't say that you
can't influence it yeah it doesn't say
doesn't say that it's locked in time
someone's turd will appear in a random
place in your home that could mean it
appears in the walls you know you have
to spit on someone and not apologize you
have a million dollars you could pay
them or you could just get a friend
that's really into that stuff and be
like hey I've got a win-win situation
here I spit on you it not so bad five
million it cool i buy you drink I don't
think I'd want someone to turn to a
random oh nice yeah I was like please
think of the wall or the fridge or in
your food the next scenario is million
dollars but every time you get angry
coffin does Ethan get angry though
probably a lot would plan
you guys have never seen me angry like
for real though we're all okay when the
Rando even the ring million dollars but
every time you get angry a fire starts
where you're standing you cannot put it
out Oh every time I get angry or
whatever wherever you are like a
building it could burn down
it just says where you're standing I
mean I guess you could run away
I guess bad burn but what happens to
wherever you're standing yeah that could
be some devastate like if you get angry
in your office oh oh gosh anyway you
have to stick your foot in an anthill Oh
every time I get angry I don't say fire
ants ya know yeah it could be nice
million dollars but every time you get
angry you become the number one suspect
in a murder case
oh that's pretty bad but that's a
suspect that doesn't mean you get
convicted yeah but that's a lot of when
they see how angry you are they're like
woo that guy don't look so nice but like
you could become thought of as an
arsonist if you like things on fire
there's a lot of like criminal things
that could happen I think we all know
which one Tyler's is yeah but to be
honest it's a murder case and you're
number one I think we all know what one
Marxist I mean you have to stick your
foot in know it's not gonna be the end
it's either between the fire 1 and the
murder 1 banger every time that's a
bunch of murder case that's a lot of
murder cases yeah that's a lot
eventually that's a lot on the fire yes
they're gonna pin me as a murderer
because they're like like 50 times this
week 50 murders I'm gonna go with the
murder one
were you the fire one of course you
would become an arsonist you would burn
down all your equipment you would lose
all of your money in the Millers racket
or Laura was or he pays someone nearby
with a fire extinguisher or he pays off
the cops
you can only are you paid guy once he's
there forever
yeah million dollars but every time you
order a meal see this is interesting
because it doesn't say when somebody
else orders for me and it doesn't say
when I cook a meal this this wouldn't
happen necessarily all that often
although lately I've I've certainly been
ordering quite a meal and well I forgot
about that aspect mark knows about that
aspect I don't know what the [ __ ] your
time I'm talking about when we on I mean
we have guests over like for shoots and
things I'm in charge of getting the food
so every time I order for those events
then it's like oh [ __ ] you all right
every time I order meal the next time
you speak to someone you have to cult
them every - there's a 10% chance the
water in your next shower will be dire
instead
you have to wax up all hair on your body
below the neck let me you like they're
all no oh I mean once it's done then the
hair would grow back this is this is
only a 10% chance I could take that [ __ ]
I could take the time I could deal with
the duties yeah what's the harm you can
shower again
oh you have any idea every day every
time any I talked to a lot of various
people I would end up calling my mother
this yeah and if you're ordering every
time you order oh my god thanks [ __ ] you
I'm guessing your diarrhea every time
you shower it's me on the other end okay
so we goofed up the camera stopped
recording but we still have the audio of
it so here's a play-by-play of what just
the [ __ ] happened
it's the butt blog podcast don't own
someone pokers through everything in
your bedroom and that's just searching
for that's interesting Nazis burned down
your house monkeys beating the [ __ ] out
of you see this isn't that bad because I
don't have like anything I like people
going through my bedroom yeah your
extensive buttplug collection I mean
it's a wonder to behold I am impressed
every time I love you guys
make a wooden butt plug and I thought
that would be splinters all day long
well that's sort of the the reason that
you have it the splinters yeah well I
mean it's like a family heirloom you
pass it down and like each button hole
smooth I mean I'm singing praise about
you but I'm a big fan of the one that
you made like in kindergarten yeah pick
a card I would run out of money fast
you know my favorite butt plug ears is
it's the the engagement blood plug that
you're saving for that special someone
I call my Christmas I can feel my
Christmas tree jiggling it's my hat oh
it's his Christmas tree blood plug very
very festive all right do you crack that
one at parties
a giant picks you up and swallows you
hold then you make the entire journey
throughout his digestive system I feel
like that'd be a cool story though be
kind of gross but we cool the B I don't
think you'd make it
yeah undamaged yeah pretty painful right
you might not die but you get like
burned by the stomach acids you know
horribly you would probably yeah I mean
this is cool so this one's out
suffocated then you would have to come
out the giant [ __ ] dream come true so
now I'm up to I have four cards I have
five I got
million dollars but every time you hear
a car honk oh oh there's so many like
car alarms that go off in there honking
oh my god every time you hear a car honk
a scorpion appears in a hidden location
near me get a giant people pimple pimple
somewhere on your body back somewhere it
doesn't say temporary pimples naturally
go away it doesn't say it's permanent
every time yeah that's a lot of them you
just go if you ever drive now you're not
gonna say I don't was gonna say that
would make me a giant pimple on Ethan
now you basically me once you hear all
those car honks I get it do my intro
[ __ ] do it let's see what you got
come on mr. Buffalo goose what is that
my cranking through this is crank game
plays whatever that's my thing deal with
it
you have to clean an entire frat house
until it's spotless that's that's pretty
bad like the Scorpion one isn't that bad
because I've picked scorpions out of
wood piles in Costa Rica they can be
interesting if you're driving this isn't
permanent the frat house wins punishment
I'll put three in there this time it's
okay don't worry about you're gonna
you're gonna be a big boy like going to
a quarter-mile that can shoot up to a
quarter mile all right you know what you
know here I'll test it you'll test it
you either either either this shoots it
at you or Tyler throws it at you full
strength I mean I want you to shoot it
at me because I'm scared of him exactly
what I scared of him more because he's a
big burly manage to test this [ __ ] make
insurance of the killing honey no okay
I'll take it just the same as you you
ready for this
yep all right I'm not gonna use a lot of
hairspray
all right that's a little harsh bro you
know you should be nicer to me I'm gonna
get punished too when you get to shoot
me first
you're you're like a brave Explorer the
frontier of existence you are the first
[Music]
[Laughter]
catch you up I'm picking now and now you
get a million dollars but any time
someone nearby sneezes you grow a
unibrow
anytime someone sneezes you have to hold
on to the last thing you were given for
a week does that mean you have to hold
it in your hand or just keep it I
suppose because it on your person I
would know it makes sense you disappear
from a photo taken in the past
oh you don't have to pick which photo
that's kind of creepy
well I mean for me there's lots of fun
that's true but what if it's like a
picture with your dad or like man okay
I'm not the sentimental type I could
deal with the unibrow I can deal with
the picture I'll go with I have to hold
on to the last thing I was giving for a
week cause anyway all right my turn is
one now I do you know I have six six and
four million dollars but whenever you
touch another human who
another key whenever I touch another
human again ik conventions every time I
touch someone what's gonna happen oh
you're about to find out
stay tuned million dollars but whenever
you touch another human you must find an
actual needle in an actual haystack
every time I touch someone else you have
to do that I have to do that that's a
lot of diving a million but they do get
a million dollars but I have to I can't
pay someone else to try and find that
needle I mean you could find more
efficient ways to do it
that's true yeah you could buy a big
needle sifting machine everything you
can soon must be done or attack threat
attack to leave tactically you're gonna
retract it so I gotta put everything ok
I'll tell you for my sumit you must hold
the hex fighter one pineapple upper body
it is feeding whenever you touch another
human you spend the next five minutes in
the choke hold of an incredibly strong
third grade bully and that counts as how
strong could that is that a third grace
is incredibly strong yeah yeah but for a
third grader well it's still incredible
sorrow that and that's human context
that's crazy
so that's done you've done heart forever
I knew that was Marcia but that that was
a really good one that was really good
it's a combo car it's a
yeah absolutely none and you may notice
that a cracker is missing that's because
he picked the Rando and then we picked
cracker and then I lost so I have to be
punished here it is you're excited yeah
the test-fires were really wimpy that
one the one that actually hit you
luckily okay it was like I think the
perfect combination was like three dads
like and then quickly we're going now oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow it was pain inflicted oh I had to go
through his whole butt plug collection
all 9000 of them that's a lot that's a
lot it was a labyrinth filled with butt
plugs he had to get to the end I know
right I did it it was great that we
paused the video so we could run to the
house and get that butt plugs I'm really
impressed by it
yeah I thank you guys for the dedication
sure actually that was just my travel
butt plug collection oh you have more
tell us what's your life a the one I
made for my
[Laughter]
so anyway that was million dollars but a
pretty fun game and I think we also
should play cards against humanity' and
I know you guys would like it so what
would you do or not do for a million
dollars let us know down in the comments
below Thank You youth and thank you
Tyler and as always we will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]